how long is it good years a lot has
happened a lot has happened that's be
honest married man got a mustache he's
back
yep Justin Bieber joined James Corden
for his third carpool karaoke on
Tuesdays The Late Late Show and dished
on all the things that have happened
since his last appearance in 2015 back
baby
now we're counting down the 7 most epic
moments from justin's ride in the front
seat starting with this I don't know
this is Ben how does being stupid to be
it's not stupid but then people were
like yeah I want to see this happen and
I was like you know what that could
actually be funny yeah Justin kind of
explained this tweet you know the one
the one he posted last June challenging
Tom Cruise to a fight I'll try not to
let my ego get in the way but there's
absolutely no there's absolutely no way
he's not the guy you see him and Justin
still thinks he could take top I'm
dangerous she does movies cool Mission
Impossible the mission is impossible and
an you makes it possible is an actor
my mind control is another I'm Cree I'm
different listen I'm the Carter
MacGregor of Entertainment the Beeb's
also opened up about marrying Haley
Bieber and you might want to grab a
tissue because it's sweet AF being
married is the best thing has ever
happened to me she's extraordinary
extraordinary cute then Justin one-upped
himself sharing this fun fact about
their wedding day yeah what did you say
I told myself I wasn't going to because
I think that's kind of weird when I'm
like going like they're like their own
artists that the thing but it's just
organic thing everything was kind of
vibing on stage so I went up and I sang
Haley one less lonely girl yeah Justin
freakin serenaded Haley with one less
lonely girl that's epic I was like you
know what you're not the one less lonely
girl you're the one last lonely girl you
know I'm sorry I did it that way and
just in case you forgot about that Bob
he's saying it for us
but that straight to camera stare though
damn anyway
justin revealed what he and his wife you
do for fun and breaking news guys stars
they're just like us we enjoy watching
movies and i'm just talking and eating
together movies talking eating and
friends how you doing Justin reveals
they binge watch the hit sitcom just
like the rest of us and he's totally a
Joey how you doing
JK he said he's actually a little bit of
all the characters Chandler Ross and
Joey because Ross is like this super
sensitive one I'm very sensitive yep
so then Chandler is also super sarcastic
and witty and I'm just I mean I'm not
gonna give myself compliments but I'd
like to say I'm a little witty and
here's a musical treat for your ears no
no not that
but Justin did remix the song friends
made famous smelly cat smelly cat smelly
cat I'm just saying is it just me or is
that actually kind of good anyway that's
it for today for all the latest on
Justin make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Holly Stephens
and I think it's only right that I send
you off with a little carpool
choreography
[Music]